c'est une île mystérieuse presque
secrète accessible seulement par bateau
ou à la nage dont le sort est en train
d'être scellé le but d'acheter ces lots
ces capotes développement et de pendre
mais les préserver dans une transaction
de 22 millions de dollars
la ville de laval met la main sur la
quasi totalité des terrains de l'île aux
vaches et de sa voisine l'île saint
pierre
niché entre terrebonne et laval elles
ont une superficie de 160 hectares à
titre d'exemple le mont royal compte 190
ha s'apprête à un endroit où les gens
pourraient faire des randonnées
pédestres avoir de l'information sur les
lézards l'histoire des arbres sur la
faune la flore les animaux qui dit on à
des populations de tortues géographique
de couleur brune qui sont vraiment en
soi sont pas mal difficile dans la
grande région de montréal
les deux il compte plus de 400 espèces
animales et végétales
on peut faire un peu la nager avec le
mont royal où ça a été décidé de
protéger certains montagne là pour pour
la recherche mais aussi maintenant pour
en faire profiter à tous les citoyens
huguette larochelle milite depuis 30 ans
pour la conservation du site
aujourd'hui elle pousse un soupir de
soulagement jusqu'à maintenant il y
avait des projets résidentiels qui était
présenté sur les 3 gilles alors nous
notre projet c'est un projet de pâques
un sentiment partagé par véronique
abelin à orniac qui habite en face d'eux
les loups vaches comme craignent
maintenant à luc st-jacques côté puis
que quelques plein d'actus vêtue et
d'autres il pourrait être racheté par la
ville le maire dit que des négociations
sont en cours
ici au faron radio canada montréal